wir sind schon immer und auch in Zukunft
die Ware klimaschutzpartei wir sind
jetzt auf diesen Satz gekommen nee alle
Entscheidungen die mit Klimaschutz mit
Ausbau von erneuerbaren übrigens auch
mit Kreislaufwirtschaft in Deutschland
zu tun haben von den 90er Jahren an sind
christlich demokratisch geführt
den Ausbau der erneuerbar sind 49,8% der
deutschen Stromerzeugung aus
Erneuerbaren erfolgt das ist ja nicht
hier habe irgendwie in 8 Monaten
geregelt sondern es ist ja ein Aufbau
gewesen der über die letzten Jahre
stattgefunden hat das Geld eine
Klimaschutzgesetz das erste und einzige
bis jetzt in Deutschland von dieser
Koalition nicht verändert ist von der
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung gemacht
von und wird übrigens gerade von der
Ampel gebrochen und nicht eingehalten
das was da entsprechend
gibt und weil wir in den Jahren
aber jedenfalls
ein Vorgaben gemacht worden und insofern
ist dass der eine Teil der andere Teil
ist ja die Herangehensweise wie schaffen
wir Klimaschutz sind sie die können
Deutschland auflösen damit ist das
Weltklima Problem noch nicht gelöst weil
wir nur zwei Prozent des CO2-Ausstoßes
machen und deswegen ist der andere
Ansatz ja wenn ich irgendwie durch diese
Panik mache oder durch festkleben Bilder
beschmieren sonst was lösen wir das
Problem nicht das Problem lösen wir doch
vor allem gerade weil wir so ein relativ
geringen Anteil haben durch Innovationen
neue Ideen durch neue Ansätze
erneuerbare Energien waren ein ganz
wichtiger Bereich aus unserer Sicht
gehören da auch Themen wie ccuccs zu
also CO2 abspalten und speichern da
gehört das Thema zu also synthetische
neue Kraftstoffe die Klima neutral sind
da gehört aus meiner Sicht Forschung
etwa auch in Kernfusion zu weil wir auf
der Welt ja noch viele viele Milliarden
Menschen sehen werden links gucken sehen
sie können sich entscheiden wollen den
Augen von Frau Witt oder die sich
überschlagen den Augen von Frau kämpfen
das ist ja ist ja okay ja weil das sagen
fällt
bei dem Ziel bei Klimaschutz passiert
immer dass man die Frage stellt will der
überhaupt so eine Politik machen oder
nicht das eigentlich Thema so ein
anderes das Ziel ist gar nicht strittig
aber so wie es bei Sozialpolitik bei
Arbeitslosigkeit bei Gesundheitspolitik
manchmal eher an Liberalen Christlich
Demokratischen Ansatz gibt und manchmal
eher ein staatszentrierten und
unterschiedliche Herangehensweise gibt
es denn beim Klimaschutz auch okay und
unsere Ansatz Herangehensweise ist
marktinstrumente und vor allem ist doch
alles in Ordnung neue Ideen und nicht
nur auf eine auf einen Fahrt zu setzen
Sie vielleicht zuerst die CDU die wahre
Klimaschutz Partei und zwar schon immer
und auch in Zukunft naja das ist ja
wirklich ein Witz also ganz ehrlich wenn
wir jetzt die 16 Jahre zurück gucken
gerade was die CDU auch zu verantworten
hat wurde die Energiewende massiv
ausgebremst es war eben so dass wir
Anfang
der erneuerbaren Energien zu fördern der
Anstieg sehr gut ging und dann kam Peter
Altmaier mit seiner angeblichen
Strompreis transbremse die aber in
erster Linie eine Bremse war das Ausbaus
der erneuerbaren Energien und danach
ging es wirklich steil bergab und das
ist die die Konsequenz die wir heute
haben ist eine gigantische Energiekrise
die ihre Partei auch mit zu verantworten
hat die gigantischen fossilen
Energiepreise die wir jetzt zu
verantworten haben kommen auch daher
dass sie Knebelverträge mit Russland
gemacht haben die uns heute wirklich
sehr sehr teuer zu stehen kommen und
deswegen kann ich dem nicht wirklich was
abgewinnen weil das sind so viele Fehler
gemacht worden die auch aufgearbeitet
ganz wichtiger Punkt Frau Kämpfer den
sie ja richtigerweise warum sind wir so
abhängig von russischem Gas
wegen der Energiewende weil wir
entschieden haben in Deutschland in
großer Mehrheit und ich glaube sogar mit
Ihrer Unterstützung aus kennen Energie
und das Kohle Energie auszusteigen wir
haben gesagt wir bauen dafür die
Erneuerbaren aus wir wissen aber auch
weil nicht immer Wind weht Sonne scheint
braucht es vor allem auch
Speichertechnologie vorzugsweise
Wasserstoff bis das richtig gut
funktioniert sind wir wahrscheinlich in
den 30er Jahren also brauchen wir als
Brücke Gas weil von im Vergleich zu
Kohle deutlich co2-freundlicher und
flexibler selbst im Koalitionsvertrag
der Ampel dezember 2021 steht noch der
Neubau von Gaskraftwerken auch die Ampel
hätte uns noch abhängiger von russischem
Gas genommen weil
natürlich warum ist es aus Russland
gekommen was mit Abstand das günstigste
war naja und deswegen waren ja diesen
Weg da entsprechend gegangen die Abfolge
die Abfolge unsere Energiepolitik die
man aus heutiger Sicht und mit dem
Wissen um diesen Krieg nicht mehr so
machen würde das kennen Energie
Aussteigen aus Kohle Energie aussteigen
und aus Gas als die einzige Brücke zu
setzen das war aus heutiger Sicht ja
nicht aber so ein wenig auf die richtig
gefunden habe nein nein wir haben immer
gewarnt davor das so zu machen und sie
haben es trotzdem gemacht gerade die
Abhängigkeit nach Russland haben wir
immer gewarnt nichts zu tun also ich
persönlich seit über 15 Jahren aber sie
haben es trotzdem getan ich habe damals
auch empfohlen ein flüssiggasterminal zu
bauen haben sie auch nicht gemacht sie
haben dann noch mehr die Abhängigkeit
nach Russland erhöht nach dem zweiber
ein Riesenfehler dieser Fehler kostet
uns heute über 300 Milliarden Euro das
ist wirklich da müssen wir wirklich
aufarbeiten das geht so nicht dass wir
das immer alles so hinstellen und keiner
kümmert sich mehr drum ich habe jetzt
eine aktuelles Buch geschrieben weil es
sonst keiner macht der wir müssen
wirklich mal in die Vergangenheit gucken
dass wir verstehen die erneuerbaren
Energien wurden ausgebremst von vieler
gemacht gerade was die hohe Abhängigkeit
zu Russland angeht das ist wirklich mein
gesamtes
vor wir hätten vor fünf Jahren gesagt
wir bauen in lg-terminal kostet 500
Millionen vielleicht bei 300 aber wir
wissen nicht haben sie immer wir wissen
noch gar nicht ob überhaupt irgendjemand
über dieses LG Terminal Gas kommen
lassen wird weil es halt viel viel
teurer ist dann hätte die Debatte in
Deutschland meine Vermutung einen
deutlich anderen Zug genommen dann war
übrigens ein LG Terminal tatsächlich
geplant ja ein Gespräch mit den USA
damals auch in dem Handelsstreit um LNG
Gas aus den USA zu nehmen dann hat er
damalige Finanzminister ist zur
Bedingung gemacht dass die USA ihre
North Stream 2 Sanktionen wegnehmen
bevor er die lng-terminals finanziert ja
es sind Fehler gemacht worden das
akzeptiere ich aber ich finde zur
Wahrheit gehört dazu dass das schon eine
ziemlich breiter gesellschaftlicher
Konsens war dass wir diesen Weg gehen
selbst nach 2014 erinnere ich mich an
Veranstaltung
wo wo eine kritische Debatte etwa einem
Wirtschaftsformen durchaus schwierig war
wir haben wirtschaftlich das stimmt über
viele Jahre von dieser günstigen Energie
aus Russland auch profitiert das hat
auch unseren Wachstum mitgekriegt hat
Faktor aus heutiger Sicht ich würde
sagen rechtfertigen heutiger Sichtweisen
Fehler der ist doch gut aber das ist
eben aber eine Erkenntnis wo man
gelegentlich schauen muss in welcher
Lage haben
können die Warnungen um uns herum waren
riesengroß aus den USA aus Europa die
ganzen Forschungen auch unsere die das
gezeigt haben die Warnung waren die
ganze Zeit da wir zahlen heute den Preis
dieser verfehlten Energiepolitik auch
der Amtszeit gerade von ihrer Partei
nicht nur ihre Partei aber gerade in der
Amtszeit der Preis der Verschleppten
Energiewende ist jetzt gigantisch und
das müssen sie auch arbeiten und
trotzdem hätte hätten mehr mehr
Windkraftanlagen die nach ihrer These
hätten wir ja viel mehr bauen können und
sollen aber selbst die würden uns ja
nicht davon bewahren dass wir
Gaskraftwerke dann noch viel mehr
gebraucht hätten nein die brauchen wir
eben nicht viel mehr die brauchen wir
nur als wenn sie mehr erneuerbare
Energien haben brauchen sie doch nicht
noch mehr wie viel Prozent des Stroms
gestern auf Kohle gekommen gestern waren
50% des Stroms aus Kohle 20%
gemacht hätten die sinnvoll gewesen
80 % erneuerbare Energien dann bräuchten
sie doch diese Menge an
Gaskraftwerke
wirklich aber die bräuchten wir dann
auch nicht machen
Experten für Energie bei den Kollegen
vom handelsbad würden sie haben gerade
gesagt ja es ist Winter und so einfach
ist die Sache nicht sagen Sie mal wie es
aus ihrer Sicht aussieht
ich glaube es gibt einen breiteren
Konsens dafür dass es zwei Jahren neue
Gaskraftwerke noch für einen bestimmten
Übergangszeit braucht aber auch nur als
sogenannte pika-anlagen das heißt die
genau dann nur hochgefahren werden wenn
eben wir gerade eine sogenannte
dunkelflaute haben die wir im besten
Falle jetzt natürlich auch nicht hätten
werden wir schon weiter aber egal
wenn dann können die und sollen die noch
mal zum Einsatz kommen ja das stimmt
aber Frau hat natürlich völlig recht wir
werden schon ganz woanders hätten wir
eine andere Politik gehabt letzten 16
Jahre geht nicht nur auf Kappe der CDU
gar keine Frage aber eben auch zum
großen Teil mit klar klar
jetzt meine Prognose wenn das was die
Ampel gerade macht so weitergeht
das ist keine Investitionssicherheit
gibt für den Bau neuer Gaskraftwerke ist
ja der Befund gerade es werden gerade es
werden wahrscheinlich im April 4 GB
kennen Energie abgestellt und es gibt
eigentlich gar keinen Ersatz dafür er
wird gerade nichts entsprechend gebaut
das wird also durch Kohle oder durch
Importe aus dem Ausland ersetzt werden
dem Zweifel nuklear oder Kohle sind wir
brauchen bis 2030 das sagt die
Bundesnetzagentur die jetzige
Bundesregierung 20 GB zusätzliche
Gaskraftwerke ich kenne nicht ein neu
angefangenes Gaskraftwerk Projekt aus
den letzten Monaten auch in dieser Zeit
gerade Gaskraftwerke wir haben
gleichzeitig gestern vorgestern
vorgestern 70% unseres Stroms aus Kohle
und aus Gas 50% aus Kohle so wir wollen
aus der Kohle raus
also muss diese 50 Prozent ja
irgendjemand ersetzen wenn dafür nicht
Gaskraftwerke bald gebaut werden und
dann ist doch die Frage zu welchem Preis
dann dann ja aber die müssen bis 2030
gebaut sein weil wir ja schrittweise bis
dahin abschalten dann wird eins
passieren dann wird man nach und nach
immer wieder sagen oh nee das können wir
jetzt doch nicht wir haben
Versorgungssicherheit und dann werden
diese alten kohlemeile die schon längst
vom Netz sein sollten noch weiter laufen
ist das Thema gar nicht ein Punkt also
ja aber ein Mini Punkt in ihrer Deckel
existieren ja aber es ist existieren in
ihrer deckwelt die erneuerbaren Energien
nicht als wenn sie nicht gäbe wir haben
auch Biomasse wir haben Wasserkraft wir
haben alle wir haben Windanlagen
Solaranlagen klar das wird in
Kombination kommen dann auch die
temporären Speicher wir haben das
europäische Umland also sie denken
analog sie kommen aus einer alten
Energiewelt denken
coole Atom und Gas
bitte aber stellt sich das aus ihrer
Sicht da hat Entschuldigung hat er
sparen dann Punkt wenn er sagt also mir
leuchtet das ein wenn es da diese diese
dieses Defizit gibt wo naja also bis
2030 hat er ja gerade zitiert gibt es
brauchen wir 20 GB 20 zusätzlich
Gaskraftwerk so Gaskraft die Zahl
variiert es gibt unterschiedliche Zahlen
20er was einen davon das ist aber auch
keine neue Erkenntnis ist das eine
Erkenntnis die ist auch schon vor der
andere Regierung geliehen jetzt mal der
Blick nach vorne ist sozusagen wie
sollten uns nicht nur mit
Vergangenheitsbewältigung beschäftigen
die Frage wie lösen wir das das doch das
Thema das ist jetzt der technisch aber
wir brauchen einen ausschreibungsdesign
und das ist auch zumindest hat der habe
ich das letzte Woche bei uns noch
angekündigt das wird im Frühjahr kommen
eine Ausschreibung zu sein dass den Bau
einer Gaskraftwerke als wäre genau wer
baut die gerade nicht so viele Menschen
freiwillig und deswegen muss das
passieren und das wird hoffentlich dann
auch kommen aber es braucht diese Zahl
diese beschreiben 50% Kohle sie haben
eben selber noch gesagt wir hatten auch
50 Prozent fast erneuerbare letztes Jahr
diese Zahl muss ja auch wachsen also die
das Ziel ist jetzt 2018 80 80 Prozent
Erneuerbare zu haben ist das
ausgesprochene Ziel jetzt ist das
natürlich ein best case und das haben
wir die letzten Jahre nie gehabt
deswegen können wir nicht davon ausgehen
dass wir dieses Ziel erreichen stimme
ich Ihnen zu ja aber wir haben ja bis
2030 und flexibel darüber hinaus bislang
auch noch die Kohle eigentlich bis 2038
aus dem Osten Deutschland
gibt es kein Klimaschutz doch wir reißen
alle Klimaschutzziele wenn Sie diese
Zahlen der Projekt sehen die sind gerade
haben weil es wirklich aus ideologischen
Gründen denken Sie nur an konventionelle
Energie sie denken nie an erneuerbare
Energien in ihrer denken die müssen ja
genau
die müssen wachsen sonst erreichen
stimmt natürlich
werden 11 neue Flüssigkeit zumindest
vielleicht gebaut die bauen die doch
alle weil sie hoffen dass sie überall
dann Gas loswerden aber wenn wir das
machen erreichen wir kein klimazeme was
wir uns vorgenommen haben deswegen ist
es so wichtig dass man ihre Denkwelt mal
erweitert um eine echte
Zukunftsfähigkeit um echte
zukunfts- und Technologien
freiheitstechnologien und auch
Technologien die uns in diesem Land
weiter welche werden das denn wir haben
ja ganz offenkundig ein CO2-Problem in
der Atmosphäre vorhin ist das Stichwort
kurz gefallen der sparen CCS Carbon
capture and storage ja steht sozusagen
dahinter also wir müssen CO2 quasi aus
der Luft holen oder bei der Produktion
und von Zement wo CO2 anfällt direkt
direkt abschalten quasi die Frage ist
Daniel Günther war letzte Woche hier
fand ich sehr interessante sagte wir
müssen diese Debatte führen notfalls
auch CO2 abscheiden und in
Schleswig-Holstein irgendwo unter die
Erde bringen
werden Sie dafür dass der Deutsche
Bundestag hat heute über CCS CCU
diskutiert auf unseren Antrag hin genau
wir haben dazu Kongress gemacht wir
haben uns das Thema noch mal auch
erarbeitet weil es dieses Verbot gibt
das früheren Entscheidung und einfach
aus unserer Sicht wir wollen den
Erneuerbaren ausbauen ich finde es immer
dass sie das immer unterstellen ich da
noch einmal ja aber der der Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren alleine
ohne alles
für ein Industrieland für Deutschland da
geht so um das Thema Wasserstoff
Wasserstoff in straff Infrastruktur
Elektrolyse jeder weiß das steht nicht
in drei Jahren sondern da werden immer
noch ein paar Jahre brauchen und für das
diese paar Jahre braucht man mindestens
mal Gas als Brücke da wir uns ja aus
allem anderen scheinbar verabschieden
wir sind halt ziemlich schnell gerade im
aussteigen ohne schon sicher zu haben
wie wir den versorgen
nur ganz kurz damit die Leute verstehen
ne wir haben ja sehr sehr
die intensive Industrien Hilfe suchen zu
Frau witch also Zement Stahl Chemie zum
Beispiel genau so da entstehen enorme
Mengen CO2 und die Idee ist sozusagen
die Norweger machen das seit Jahrzehnten
schon die USA alle möglichen machen das
also man scheidet sozusagen das CO2
direkt bei der Produktion ab und dann
ist die Frage wohin damit und das große
Tabu in Deutschland Schleswig-Holstein
hat sich irgendwann sich die Leute sehr
dagegen gewehrt und biologisch würde das
gehen sagt ist verboten
und sagt das sollten wir auch bei uns
machen statt das wäre die Alternative
und wieder extrem teuer die Norweger
selbstlos wie sie sind sagen wir machen
das für euch
ironisch die Frage ist und das lassen
wir uns dann sehr sehr teuer bezahlen
aber die Frage ist da wo macht das Sinn
macht Sinn nach allem was man was man
aktuell sieht und weiß eben auch in
großen entsprechenden sozusagen Kavernen
natürlichen im in der Nordsee zum
Beispiel das macht dass die Norweger das
machen das auch andere der
skandinavischen Länder das machen sein
es kann sein dass es auch an der
Deutschen in der deutschen Küstenregion
entsprechende Dinge gibt das muss man
explorieren und da muss man darüber
reden ob man das nützen will das ist das
war ja die Frage besser ist ja ein
Unterschied die Debatte damals in
Deutschland war eine wollen wir das
sozusagen unter der Erde machen in den
dicht besiedelten Raum da gab es starke
Zurückhaltung die Frage ist ja ist das
überhaupt notwendig ich würde gerne die
neuen klimaparteien CDU verstehen wollen
ich habe doch gerade gesagt auf unseren
Antrag hat der Deutsche Bundestag diese
Debatte geführt und in diesem Antrag
steht das ist genau der Weg den wir
gehen sollten wo wir internationaler
Kooperation aber auch national eben
miteinander diese Dinge angeht und dafür
auch das Gesetz ändern ich sage halt nur
noch einmal der oder ich sag's der
klimaschutzminister habe ich den
unterstützen wir auch in seine
Ankündigung des Tee tun zu wollen er war
ja auch in Norwegen
um das zu machen ich stelle mir fest
dass seine eigene Partei diesen Weg
nicht mit ihm gehen würde
die klimaschutzpartei CDU beim Thema CCS
CCU den
klimaschutzschützen
also das ist doch wirklich also CCS die
Frage können wir CO2 auch irgendwo in
Deutschland einlagern muten wir uns
diese gesellschaftliche Debatte zu
wissen
heißes Thema genau nicht nur das Herr
Land sondern muten wir uns zu dass wir
unsere Speicher die wir haben in
Norddeutschland mit CO2 füllen oder
wollen wir da nicht Geothermie nutzen
wollen wir da nicht wasserstoffspeichern
wir haben begrenzte Speicher der gibt's
nur zu Konkurrenz und deswegen wie sie
ist für Deutschland tatsächlich nicht
für Norwegen die machen das die haben
auch die Technologien da geht's in der
nktiv sehr aber die Umwelt Risiken sind
da und die sind auch nicht weniger man
weiß nicht ob es wirklich nicht
entweicht ob es irgendwelche
auswirkungen hat auch auf der Tiefsee
auf die Biologie dort also die beraten
die dort leben das ist unsicher ist CO2
dann in der Nordsee zu versenken ist
jetzt auch nicht die nette Art an aber
das ist die einzige Alternative die im
Moment der ernsthaft diskutiert wird das
was in die Nordsee bringen und da auch
einlagern das soll ja sogar Pipelines
gebaut werden und das ist wahnsinnig
teuer das war teuer hat noch mal wieder
die Energie wie wir haben doch aktuell
schon sowohl ihre Lösung kein Zement
mehr produzieren nein das ist genau die
Fragen nein also bei zement ist reden
wir über einzelne Industrien jetzt haben
wir ja die ganze Zeit CCS dass ich
tatsächlich sehr kritisch aber CCU da
gibt es an wendungsmöglichkeiten das ist
aber das CO2 dass man es dann irgendwie
in Gestein nimmt oder dass man es weiter
verwendet in Materialien das ist
tatsächlich möglich aber da ist auch die
Möglichkeit dass für die Industrie zu
tun aber die Schwerindustrie natürlich
können die auch das CO2 weiter nutzen
und man kann sie auch umstellen auf
damit die Zuschauer uns Folgen können
dann grüner wasserstoffen Spiel
wasserstoff ist der Champagner unter den
die Trägern aus wahnsinnig aufwendig
hergestellt werden bis zu acht Mal mehr
erneuerbare Energien müssen sie ausbauen
sie wollen ja jetzt schon nicht
weniger
es sind ja die erneuerbaren Energien das
ist ja genau das wovon
zu Ende gesprochen weil der Wasserstoff
muss kostbar hergestellt werden in
Deutschland wenig aber wir können ihn
importieren zum Beispiel auch
sonnenreichen Ländern Marokko oder Chile
was im Moment auch im Kooperation ich
würde dann ein Punkt widersprechen ich
glaube schon dass wir die CO2
Speicherung auch und das habe ich ja
auch beim Thema Tracking auch schon mal
hier gesagt diskutieren sollten in
Deutschland einfach weil wir diskutieren
müssen wir können ja dieses Thema nicht
totschweigen haben dann wieder die
Debatte wir lagern alles aus aber machen
in der Heimat so wenn man muss es einmal
diskutieren ich glaube Sie haben Recht
also zumindest aus dem Gesprächen mit
ExpertInnen die ich so führe habe ich
die Rückmeldung bekommen das ist in
Deutschland schwierig ist unterirdisch
nicht nur gesellschaftlich sondern ob
das so sinnvoll ist da das
wirtschaftliche Themen und anderes das
stimmt aber diskutieren sollten das ja
und ich glaube also das sagt ja auch der
weltklimaat wir werden auch die
Speicherung leider brauchen aber das ist
natürlich sonst das 1,5 Grad Ziel gar
nicht mehr erreichen können wir müssen
irgendwann glaube ich CO2 wirklich aus
der Atmosphäre holen
ganz kurz für sie der Geophysiker
Hans-joachim ich weiß nicht ob in der
was sagt der der war vor einiger Zeit
hier etwas Interessantes gesagt er sagte
auf die Frage ob man CO2 im Boden
speichern könnte meinte ja natürlich
kann man das überlegen Sie mal wie viel
Gas wir in der Erde speichern ja immer
faktisch keine Gasometer mehr in
Deutschland hat er recht ja und wir
speichern Sie in der er hat irgendwie
auch keiner ein Problem damit warum also
nicht auch CO2 ich habe ihn dann gefragt
ganz kurz zum Thema
hochrisikotechnologie was daraus
irgendwann wird und er sagt ist eine
Frage der Zeit das kann weniger Jahre
dauern es kann auch tausend Jahre dauern
aber irgendwann wird daraus Carbonat
Gestein ja ist
ist dann versteinert wenn man so will er
lernt so viel Speicher haben wir eben
nicht deswegen konkuriert das eben auch
mit anderen also wenn wir jetzt noch
Geothermie machen wollen oder wenn wir
Wasserstoff machen wollen
ja aber ich meine so viele haben wir da
nicht die Nordsee wäre da eher was was
man sich vorstellen könnte deswegen muss
man da muss man wirklich gucken was man
anguckt aber mein Punkt ist sehr wir
müssen es CO2 vermeiden immer als aller
aller erstes vermeiden vermeiden
vermeiden es geht um unvermeidbare
Emissionen und die sind wirklich nicht
so hoch ja und dann kann man damit auch
machen das Problem ist und das höre ich
bei Ihnen wie bei anderen häufig raus
ist dass man über gar nichts anderes
mehr diskutieren kann als über den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren weil sie bei
jeder anderen Debatte die Sorge haben
dass deswegen die Erneuerbaren nicht
mehr ausgebaut werden soll nach dem
Motto so ist jetzt CCS auch mal seit dem
Motto nachher lassen die Kohlekraftwerke
weiterlaufen scheiden co2-app genau und
dann wollen die erneuerbare gar nicht
ausbauen lange Debatte darüber führen ob
das nicht eigentlich ein Thema
Neutralität denn dann geht
an der Stelle aber unabhängig davon ist
mein Eindruck und das gilt auch bei ein
paar anderen Themen übrigens auch bei
Kernfusion jetzt mal in der Mittel in
der Mittel und langfrist dass du aus
dieser Angst man würde erneuerbare nicht
mehr ausbauen wollen wenn man sich auch
mit anderen Technologien beschäftigt ist
da wir handeln Begriff Lobby heute schon
mal gehabt den will ich gar nicht
bemühen aber viele Interessen gibt die
überhaupt nicht anderes mal reden wollen
darüber erneuerbar und jetzt sage ich
noch einmal wir wollen erneuerbare
ausbauen wir tragen mit 80% wir gehen
den Weg ja mit aber ich möchte halt dass
wir etwas breiter auf das Thema
Technologie und Alternativen und
zusätzliche Möglichkeiten schauen dazu
gehört ccuccs dazu gehört das Thema im
übrigen sehen sie auch anders weiß ich
aber eh für uns synthetische Kraftstoffe
für den Verkehrsbereich das Thema aus
meiner Sicht ganz wichtig die Kernfusion
mal auch hier in Deutschland
entsprechend zu unterstützen auch mit
den Ansätzen einfach bei der
Lasertechnik die ist da neu gibt aber
das kann irgendwann mal sein dass in 10
15 Jahren dass sowas ist wie man eine
ganz neue Technologie die auf einmal
tatsächlich in der Anwendung das möchte
ich nicht irgendwie nur aus China dann
entsprechend sehen da geht es auch zum
Teil um quantencomputing und künstlicher
Intelligenz wenn es um
Energieeffizienz und anderes geht es
gibt so viel mehr als nur den Ausbau
erneuerbaren und unser deutscher Fokus
ist immer nur darauf dass wir dieses
eine Thema haben und das wollen wir halt
gerne weiter
Kernkompetenz im Bereich Wirtschaft ja
und die Frage die Sorge auch um den
Industriestandort Deutschland bevor wir
dann auch gleich Frau Quadbeck Fragen
hat er recht Frau mit wenn er sagt ein
ein hoch entwickeltes Industrieland wie
Deutschland das auch so Energie hungrig
ist kann natürlich vielleicht
perspektivisch irgendwann nur von
erneuerbaren Leben das auch
entsprechende speicherfähigkeiten gibt
aber nicht kurzfristig wir brauchen
jetzt andere Technologie zusätzlich ich
glaube dass Programm was die CDU da
aufgeschrieben hat hat viele wichtige
Punkte und es ist ja erstmal gut dass
man nach vorne stellt aber es befasst
sich eben mit all den Punkten die Sie
gerade gesagt haben ausschließlich das
heißt es befasst sich gar nicht damit
wie können wir den Erneuerbaren Ausbau
voranbringen oder wie können wir
Speicher ausbauen und ich glaube das
Thema ist wir brauchen ja alles parallel
also Sie haben Recht mit dem was sie
sagen ja warum soll man nicht an der
Kernfusion forschen aber nicht als im
Hinterkopf habend dass das die Lösung
ist oder dass das uns retten kann
sondern dass man hofft in der
Grundlagenforschung die es ist weil so
weit weg ist es ja zehnte weg von einer
Realisierung es ist wirklich noch mal
betrogen ich mich manchmal unterhalte
nicht in Unternehmen tätig sind die sich
damit beschäftigen eine einen tolle Idee
und unbedingt weiter forschen aber es
ist Grundlagenforschung es ist noch
nicht mal bewiesen und es ist ganz weit
weg ja weiter daran forschen weil da
können sinnvolle Dinge rechts und links
abfallen aber es muss eben sein
Deutschland und deswegen auf ihre Frage
antworten was heißt kurzfristig also
können wir 2030 ist schaffen
[Musik]
nein kann Deutschland kurzfristig bzw
mittelfristig wenn die Ziele erreicht
sind auch als Industrieland so bestehen
natürlich die Technologien sind da im
Gegensatz zu Kernfusion sind diese
Technologien die wir brauchen alle da